sir you went to the same mosque as
Alexander Nolan that is jaim Israel the
man who did the beheading recently in
Oklahoma City and has become the subject
of some controversy is some contend that
his attack was related to his conversion
to Islam and perhaps even what he
learned in the mosque and other people
deny that and of course the mosque in
question is the Islamic Society of
Greater Oklahoma City when did you go
there and how did it come about that you
started going there I became a Muslim in
late February of
2001 just several months before the 9/11
attacks um
I joined the mosque after
a fairly lengthy
search into the Islamic
faith and what happened was is I had
always been kind of antagonistic towards
Islam not necessarily openly so but I
didn't believe in it obviously because I
was raised in raised in a Catholic
home and I met a guy in my 11th grade
year in high
school
um that was it actually might have been
my 12th grade year I don't recall
exactly but I was 18 years old I
remember
that I met a guy in my psychology class
that was a musone from
Pakistan and his name was Rasheed
and at first I was kind of antagonistic
towards him in a more joking
Manner
and just out of curiosity I started to
ask him about his
faith and he would answer some of my
questions and the ones he couldn't
answer he would take home to his father
who knew a little bit more about Islam
than he
did and after a while my
questions were so many that just decided
that it might be better if I just came
to the mosque and try ask somebody my
questions
so I finally one day went with him to
the
mosque
and that was where I first had my actual
encounter in an Islamic
mosque and over
time after asking quite few
questions
um I decided that I would accept the
Islamic faith and I said my
shahada in late February of
2001 now I was asked one of the
questions asked was how did I feel when
I first went in there well when I first
went in there I kind of felt like an
odity because most of the people in the
mosque are not white I am white I'm an
Oki I'm born and raised in Oklahoma
City
and I felt a little uncomfortable
because everybody kind of looked at me
not in a bad way but as a
curiosity I noticed however that the
Imam who I later Learned was s
web was a white guy and I found that
kind of interesting and I saw a couple
other white faces around the mosque but
for the most part they were kind of
looking at
me in a way that kind of made me curious
and yet a little
uncomfortable and I would later learn
that white people becoming Muslim is
such a rarity at least it was before
9/11
that they almost look at you like a fish
they're trying to reel in and also at
the same time they look at you a little
skeptically like maybe you might you
know be an informant or you might be a
cop cuz I've had people looked at it
that way I've heard stories of white
people coming into Moss from other
Muslims and a random person will accuse
them of being in the
FBI so it's just it was kind of
interesting I think they didn't know
what to make of me and I think they they
find white people kind of a curiosity at
first and that was my first experience
with Islam but after like I said after a
study I decided to become a Muslim and I
became a Muslim actually on February
25th of 2001 when you were regularly
attending the Islamic Society of Greater
Oklahoma City did you regularly hear or
even occasionally he talk about Jihad
about Sharia the necessity to implement
the Sharia Islamic supremacist
statements or did everything you hear
coincide perfectly with the uh General
mainstream media view that mosques are
made up entirely of people who are
patriotic Americans who completely
accept constitutional principles and
freedoms there's always a talk of
Islamic supremacism now most MOS are not
when they know that there are strangers
among them and often there are with
people especially now after
911 but before 9/11 as well um they tend
to watch what they say open
and a lot of the more negative stuff
you'll hear in smaller groups and you
tend to have to be one of the crowd to
be able to hear it now even while I was
studying to be Muslim I heard you know
that one day Islam will be the religion
of the entire world now that's not
openly threatening but you know it's an
interesting thing that they believe
but I was taught later after I
converted and by web himself actually
sitting out in his car when he dropped
me off of my home when I brought up the
subject of
jihad he said basically the way it works
is according to Islam in the Hadith the
prophet Muhammad said that the Muslim
people are to give non-believers three
choices you either convert you either
invite you invite them to Islam if they
don't want to do that you invite them to
live under Islamic Rule and pay what's
called aizia or pole tax and the third
option if they reject both of those is
to fight
them
now um some of the other things that I
heard were open support at least among
Muslims for
Hamas Islamic
Jihad um any of those anti-israel groups
because Islamic
groups because and they supported
suicide bombing they would never tell
the media this I was specifically told
at one point don't bring that up with
the media because they will not
understand they said that the reason
that it's okay is because that's the
only weapon according to them that the
Palestinians
have now they wouldn't share it with the
media but they shareed it with us with
when they knew that there were no
strangers
around other things that I experienced
were is that I was sitting with some
Muslims that was close to um one was yah
graph who know him M by the way the
other is a man named Jihad Rashad both
white convert and they both explicitly
told me that if Osama Bin Laden were to
come to their door and ask for help they
would help him because he's our Muslim
brother
um that was kind of concerning to
me
um later on I was approached by another
couple of Brothers one named suan it was
actually from what I was told was a
Jewish convert to Islam and another one
who was in the military named
Rasheed um I don't know if he was in the
military at the time I met him but he
had been um they invited me to go shoot
guns up north of Oklahoma City now I'm
an Oki as I said I was raised with guns
and so I had no issue with this when we
got up
there um we laid out some targets and
suon the Jewish convert mentioned to me
that we were going to call each one we
were going to call this Target George W
bush we were going to call this target
Ario Chone and I don't remember who else
he named them and I later had a
conversation with suan about what was
going on in Iraq um some of the
beadings um and he mentioned to
me
that
um this was acceptable
because these the these people were
Crusaders and they did not belong in
Islamic lands and the people of Iraq are
free to do with these people as they
chose
and so man I always remember him because
he wore a BDU jacket at the time much
like the one Osama Bin Laden's been
pictured to wear with the shahada
written on one of the breast
pockets and it was things like this that
concerned me because like I said they're
not going to say much about this in
front of the media they're just not
they're not going to say it among
strangers you have to be among friends
to be able to hear
this kind of stuff but they teach that
Islam will one day conquer the world and
that Jesus will come back and will break
the cross and kill the Pig and the
entire world will be
Islamic so they believe in Jihad whether
they say they do or not and if you're
there long enough you're going to hear
it in the wake of the beheading a lot of
the mosque leaders have been saying that
jaim Israel was a bad Muslim he put the
Quran on the floor and so on he was a
little bit odd and above all that he is
far away from Islam do you think that
their teaching has changed in the
Islamic Society of Greater Oklahoma City
since you went there how would you
respond to the contention that what jaim
Israel did in the beheadings uh that is
the uh beheading of the one lady in the
attempted beheading of a second has
nothing to do with what he learned at
the mosque I would say you need to
understand Islamic teaching and you also
need to understand the concept that
these people are not going to tell you
exactly what they believe especially in
European countries that have more
liberal
um um systems of government than an
Islamic country
would um they're going to try to stay
under the radar when it comes to being
in front of the media they're not going
to draw unwanted attention unless
they're actually trying to do something
but even then they're not going to
openly
invite the FBI or the authorities I mean
to have a reason to come in and bust
them they're going they're trying to
build up um the Muslim
population but they do teach according
to
Islam that Islam will rule the world by
necessary will be through Force if you
know Islamic history as I've learned and
if you know what the Hadith says the Sor
like 9: 29 say when it comes to the
people of the bws and Christians and I'm
not just saying them it's polytheists
are
included it teaches
that you either convert you live under
Islamic Rule and pay the jiz tax and
feel yourself subdue meaning you live as
a second class citizen in a lowly state
or you get fought against so
they can deny it all they want they can
present themselves as good
citizens But ultimately they're loyal to
their
faith and their faith
teaches global domination when did you
sto going to the mosque and why I left
the um Islamic Society of Greater
Oklahom City and the Islamic States
itself in the spring of 2003 about two
years later but some of the people you
knew are still still there is that
correct and uh some of them are actually
some of the people you knew as Muslims
are now imams is that right yes when I
left um I still kept track of some of
the people I knew because we had been
friends not because I was still friends
with them just to see where they
were when I left um a few years later I
presented in this information some of it
to authorities and I can't say much more
than that I did try to pass it along
because I was concerned
and I did go back a few times um because
a lot of people didn't know I
left and I tried to hear what else was
going on and nothing's changed but yes I
am aware that um yah graph is a an Imam
um if you look on the Islamic Society of
great Oklahoma City's website if you
look at the uh sermon um archives it
even lists him as an Imam the last
already might be one in Houston but I've
also been told he still lives in Cairo
Egypt because he and Su both moved to
alasar to study can you identify the two
people in the picture on the couch the
two that are on the couch are yah grath
who's an Imam and Jihad Rashad who is a
member of the Islamic Society of great
Oklahoma City and has given a sermon at
the MOs before and the Imam is the one
on the left or on the right um it's the
uh one with the actual hair to the bald
one is Jihad Rashad based on your
personal experience and speaking with
members of the mosque how typical do you
think is the teaching uh that you got at
the Islamic Society of Greater Oklahoma
City compared to what you might have
heard in some other mosque in the United
States do you think that the Islamic
Society of Greater Oklahoma City is more
radical than other mosques in the US or
is it uh unfortunately rather
typical I'd say it's it's pretty
consistent I mean they teach their
religion they know when to keep it quiet
and who to
share the
more tough things for Americans to
accept but it's consistent with stuff
that's taught in other mosques around
the United States I've been to several
mosques in Oklahoma I've actually been
to pretty much every mosque in Oklahoma
City I believe at the time when I was
there there were three there's two right
now one them I believe is being
renovated um and I've been to the one in
Tulsa and it's all the same I've also
been the one in Edmund and they're all
consistent why did you ultimately decide
to leave Islam I was concerned with the
teachings of Islam when it came to
violence I was concerned with legalistic
aspect of the religion the way God
didn't seem to be a loving
God and I was more attracted to the
Christian concept of of a loving Eternal
Father and I had been raised Catholic as
I mentioned and I just found after a
while that concept of
God um that didn't ask me to kill other
people in his
name um a lot more appealing so
ultimately one day I left
and and I've been away now for 11 and A2
years I believe
is there a threat to your personal
safety because of your
apostasy there the teaching of Islam
says that the one that leaves his faith
is to be
killed I'm
concerned I'm not concern so much for
myself the only reason I ask to be
obscured for the safety of my loved
ones but I know that certain people will
not act because they would a lot of
attention but there are those that do
not
care um and that I am concerned about
that but not so much for myself